hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another video edition of ask Evan in
today's video I'm going to answer
questions from one of my readers Jackie
who's struggling to make Twitter work
for the business so here's Jackie's
question we've been trying over and over
to make Twitter work for us but it's
been harder than expected not quite sure
what to do next so Jackie I'm a big fan
of Twitter and I'm going to share with
you some of the ways that i use it and
hopefully there's some lessons that you
can use for your business as well so the
first thing I like to do in twitter is
follow my customers and as much as
possibly try to get the twitter IDs of
our customers on not everybody will have
a twitter account but if they do ask for
it and start to follow them and then we
look for ways to get involved in their
lives and be meaningful so for example
somebody might post an article that they
just posted from their blog potentially
that they're really proud of so we might
write back to them and congratulate them
on the great post we also look for ways
to send them stuff wherever possible we
try to actually send our customers
brownies every week so we look for an
opportunity to Twitter so an example one
of our customers posted on twitter that
the air conditioning broke down in her
office on a really hot day so she was
working from starbucks so we sent her
brownies we said we saw your tweet and
we wanted to send you some brownies to
you don't give me some sweets for the
day and she was over the moon excited
you know wasn't expecting anything like
that and it's a great way to be able to
connect with your customers outside of
your regular business operation so you
don't have to actually send anything to
people even just recognizing them and
commenting on some other tweets helps
you build a personal connection with
them and the next time they're
interested in buying 100
services though more likely to come to
you and spend more money and refer more
friends and family because they know
when they like you so it's a great way
to start building relationships with
customers so as much as possible you can
try to follow your customers the next
thing that I'd like to use clear for is
to share content that I find interesting
and exciting so I read a lot of books
and blogs and articles and they'll often
post on my twitter feed information that
I find interesting that's helped me grow
my business or inspirational quotes from
famous entrepreneurs that helped me you
know stay motivated want to continue to
drive my business forward and that's all
value I'd content that's not necessarily
promoting anything on my site it's just
trying to add value to my readers so
things that I find interesting and then
people will start to follow you and you
get known as an expert for whatever Gary
a drink so everything and I post is
usually around entrepreneurship so
whatever industry you're in try to
become the expert by posting interesting
and relevant content on your twitter
feed it could be links to content that
you've created but it could also be just
other content that you find really
interesting and you think your readers
would benefit from let in the last part
is we do have some emotional stuff that
will put on our twitter feed is a
contest we're promoting or new blog post
we put out that we really want to get
some attention to and that's okay to
have some promotional content in there
you have coupons or contest going on i
try to keep the ratio lo so try to add a
lot of value and try to connect with
your customers as much as possible and
then every now and then when you have
important contracts or promotions that
really want to get out there you have a
following if all you're doing is
blasting out promo offers people aren't
really going to follow you and pay
attention you just kind of screaming ads
at them so you want to add value build a
relationship and then when you do have
marketing messages they're much more
likely to want to pay attention to it
and find value in it so I hope that
helps if you have any other specific
questions let me know it would be happy
to walk you through
bit more for anybody who liked the video
please give it a thumbs up if you do
I'll create more just like it and it
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below and stay tuned for the next
episode
you
you